maintenant parlons du logement parce que
dans un mois exactement il ya des
ministres québécois qui vont déménager
mais plusieurs familles font face
actuellement un défi de taille est la
pénurie de logements juin à québec
véronique laflamme qui porte parole du
front d'action populaire en
réaménagement urbain le frapru madame la
flamme bonjour bonjour le 1er juillet
arrive à grand pas est ce que vous vous
inquiétez d'une crise du logement cette
année en fait la pénurie importante de
logements dans la région de montréal
entre autres à gatineau nous inquiète
énormément déjà à gatineau il ya des
familles qui sont sans logis qui sont
hébergées notamment en motel donc
effectivement les t'inquiète pas on voit
les taux d'inoccupation si beaux arts à
montréal dans tous les quartiers entre
autres pour les logements familiaux mais
malheureusement là la rareté des
logements abordables de toutes tailles
nous fait craindre pour les conséquences
de cette pénurie d'eau à court terme
mais également à moyen terme vous avez
dit madame la femme qui a des familles à
gatineau et à montréal qui sont hébergés
dans des motels pas montréal encore à
gatineau
les baux se termine - autour du 1er
juillet depuis le mois d'avril il ya eu
cinq familles donc des couples avec
enfants qui se sont retirés perdu leur
logement et qui se sont retrouvées à la
rue
donc si malheureusement un organisme
communautaire qui leur vient en aide et
qui doit défrayer les factures
d'hébergement temporaire à l'heure
actuelle en l'absence là de mesures
suffisantes de la part du gouvernement
du québec
parce qu'on parle beaucoup souvent des
membres de montréal quand on parle de
pénurie de logements mais gatineau est
également 60 pénurie actuellement on
parle de moins d'un pour cent de
logements disponibles en c'est ça qu'est
ce qui explique la situation là-bas à
gatineau effectivement c'est la bible où
le taux d'inoccupation est le plus bas
il ya les tornades de l'an passé entre
autres les inondations vont sûrement mis
de la pression sur un taux
d'inoccupation qui était déjà à 0.6 7%
montréal n'est pas bien loin le avec un
taux d'inoccupation de 1.9 mais comme je
vous le disais pour les logements
familiaux on est plus autour du zéro
point et de la savoie de 0.2 à 0.8 selon
les quartiers donc c'est extrèmement bas
c'est très préoccupant aussi à laval
longueuil couronne nord cours de
montréal mais dans d'autres villes
également
plus éloignées des grands centres il ya
une baisse drastique dans la plupart des
villes cette année du taux
d'inoccupation a oui donc c'est pire que
dans les années précédentes
ça fait 14 ans à montréal qu'on n'avait
pas eu un taux d'inoccupation aussi bas
et comme je vous le disais la belle dans
la plupart des ve et leur apprennent et
une baisse sous le seuil des 3% du taux
général d'occupation au québec donc ça
fait très longtemps également la con on
n'était pas dans une situation aussi
préoccupante et c'est pour ça qu'on
réclame des mesures à court terme pour
aider les gens mais aussi des gestes
forts politiquement pour atténuer cette
crise-là éviter qu'on se retrouve dans
une situation comme celle qu'on l'a
connu au début des années 2000 où on
avait des gens qui étaient à la rue
carrément par dizaines mais qu'on avait
également beaucoup de logements qui a
été transformé en condominiums or au
cours des dernières années
ce serait vraiment pas le même prix
mensuellement on en conviendra
qu'est ce qui peut être fait vous dites
il faut des gestes forts pour améliorer
la situation alors qu'est ce que vous
demandez au gouvernement d'abord il faut
mieux protéger le parc de logements
locatifs on parle beaucoup d'airbnb
c'est une réalité à montréal mais
également dans des petites villes union
attrait touristique
avec l'été qui s'en vient ça va mettre
la pression encore plus déjà en gaspésie
par exemple les gens de la misère à
avoir banni 12 mois par année donc il
faut mieux protéger le parc de logements
locatifs agir contre airbnb mais il faut
développer des logements sociaux des
coopératives et osbl d'habitation pour
qu'il y ait une alternative à ce marché
privé qui est devenu beaucoup trop cher
pour une part importante des ménages
locataires qui ne peuvent pas payer 1500
1800 dollars voire 2000 $ pour se loger
à chaque mois de salaire minimum
on n'y arrive pas donc il faut plus de
logements sociaux
et malheureusement la caq n'investit pas
suffisamment à l'heure actuelle alors on
interpelle le gouvernement pour qu'il
qu'ils reviennent sur ces décisions là
et qu'il donne un grand coup pour
s'assurer qu'on développe suffisamment
de logements qui vont répondre aux
besoins des locataires et comme vous
disiez les cordeaux malheureusement il
s'en construit beaucoup un peu partout
surtout à montréal gatineau québec
mais malheureusement les on le voit il y
avait déjà des familles à l'heure
actuelle qui ont un revenu qui est
insuffisant pour se payer les rares
logements disponibles alors il faut agir
maintenant pour éviter là que la
situation ne se propage
oui puis ça va passer vite ans il reste
quatre semaines avant la fin officielle
de milliers de baud au québec véronique
laflamme merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin ça fait plaisir vraiment une
journée